[Musik]
brötchen semmel oder schritte sebastian
fordert einen traditionellen
bäckermeister heraus und zeigt mit
welchen tricks die großbäckereien die
preise drücken was na das sind ja schon
mal vielversprechend aus nico wie
brötchen ja wichtig du bist schon
bewusst dass ich wachse ja ich versuche
ja ich habe mir natürlich
dementsprechend paar helfer laimer
eingepackt ja hier sind 13 zutaten und
wahnsinn
also dass sie macht eigentlich alles die
brötchen backmischung original aus dem
großhandel mit lauter legalen
zusatzstoffen für besonders günstige
teiglinge so ersetzt die industrie viele
teure zutaten und macht das packen so
einfach wie möglich
und du meinst wirklich so viel besser
auf jeden fall 100 prozent qualität
braucht ihre zeit und ihre guten
rohstoffe also ich bin voll überzeuge
werden ein unterschied feststellen ok
dann würde ich sagen machen wir den tag
und lege los oder sebastian benutzt mail
mit ascorbinsäure das beschleunigt die
reife dazu die backmischung hier habe
ich ja schon 13 zutaten drin alles in
einer schale
statt teurer butter steckt tanzen fed im
billig brötchen dazu frische hefe und
enzyme helfen beim aufgehen und zum
schluss wasser
jetzt nur noch kneten lassen
ja meint icloud anleitungen vier bis
fünf nutzer nicht einmal fünf minuten
braucht das industrie brötchen
schnell entsteht das wichtige kleber
gerüst in teig das ist wichtig für die
stabile form klimabüros wie du siehst
hast du aber trotz der kurzen zeit hier
so macht es die industrie jetzt der
handwerksbäcker los geht's mit dem
super-g und brötchen was mainz hingegen
die schlagen soll
da bin ich mal gespannt die zutaten für
das handwerks brötchen natürliches
unbehandeltes mail ein vorteig der die
brötchen aromatisch nacht dazu kommt
noch butter gerstenmalz zucker hefe salz
und eiskaltes wasser
so und wie lange das super jetzt rühren
und kneten wir werden jetzt ungefähr 15
minuten in der milch phase und dann
kneten teig nummer vier minuten alleine
die knie zeit ist beim handwerks
brötchen viermal länger als beim
industrietag
[Musik]
ist das schön glatt ist dieses brötchen
wirst du keine chance haben jetzt muss
der handwerkstag erst einmal 30 minuten
ruhen da kann sebastian die industrie
brötchen schon ofen fertig machen
den kennen
die jungs das sieht eher aus wie eine
kaulquappe was ich hier gerade mache
aber okay sagt doch bei dem
handwerklichen können hier was das
backen angeht da hilft auch kein
backmittel die industrie brötchen müssen
nun für 30 minuten in den kühlschrank
das dauert aber bei dir auch wieder
alles er hätte schon alles wenig senken
was machst du jetzt mit seinem brötchen
die werden jetzt 24 stunden in die
kühlung gestellt wie kühl und meine habe
ich war gerade in den schrank gestellt
ja du willst ja auch deine wohl schnell
machen du hast ja auch keine zeit 24
stunden gegen 30 minuten im wer schrank
ein gigantischer zeitvorteil für die
industrie deswegen hat nico schon mal
was vorbereitet
nach einem tag in der kühlung haben die
brötchen ein schönes volumen bekommen
erschrecken sie hier wirklich gefallen
lassen ja sie sind sensibel
hast du nicht machen genau dieses
brötchen werden wir nachher wieder
finden weil es so flach sein wird
[Musik]
klappe zu und start weg beide brötchen
müssen jetzt für 20 bis 25 minuten in
den ofen
doch mal an die top teile und vor allen
dingen hat dafür riesen april los und da
kann so richtig lange von essen surprise
surprise
auf den ersten blick sehen beide cross
und lecker haus holten also die meiste
oder geruch spreche mal eins auf das ist
ein bisschen ihm allein vom boden bist
du dass diese farbe die strukturen
aufbrechen
ja er bricht ganz anders riecht ja ist
auf alle fälle der geruch ist auf alle
für total anders mein name ein bisschen
was ein pappkarton finde ich betrachten
wir nur die zeit gewinnt das industrie
brötchen unser duell
hier stehen zwei stunden gegen 26
in sachen qualität gewinnt der
handwerksbäcker seine brötchen sind
schön aufgeplatzt und haben eine
goldbraune kruste bleibt das preis duell
und da hat das industrie brötchen klar
die nase vorn
10.10 zu 50 cent ich meint klar
hier schafft sogar so lange wie ich im
brötchen zu backen
denn nico jahrelange erfahrung zutaten
ganz oben aus dem regal gegriffen die
zeit ist das a und o bei qualität und
geschmack teuer oder billig diese
entscheidung liegt beim kunden
wie die billig brötchen im masse
produziert werden schauen wir uns bei
harry brot in magdeburg an
für das tochterunternehmen back factory
und diverse supermärkte laufen hier
täglich drei millionen brötchen vom band
harry brot hat die industrielle
herstellung von brot und brötchen
perfektioniert mit einem teig der sich
vollautomatische arbeiten lässt ganz
ohne zusatzstoffe kommt der aber nicht
aus setzen wir noch einige das ist
weiter du erkennen merke mir mit
zugesetzt um die wasseraufnahme den tag
zu erhöhen dass das gepäck wird dadurch
länger frisch und er setzt noch ein
emulator damit wird der teig etwas
dehnbarer man hält ein schönes kind
geweckt
die zusatzstoffe sind nötig damit der
teig nicht in den maschinen kleben
bleibt und viel wichtiger
damit die brötchen auch halbfertig ihre
form behalten
denn harry bat die brötchen nur an und
friert sie dann bei minus 18 grad ein
die sogenannten teiglinge werden nach
bedarf an die filialen geliefert und
sind bis zu zehn monate haltbar
1996 hat harry brot diese prepaid
verfahren eingeführt
der bot beim chemisch system ist einfach
dass sie die ware halt immer bevorraten
können
das heißt wir können auch so engpässe
hier an feiertagen oder weihnachten im
vorfeld schon anrufe an dem wir dort
mehr produzieren so dass wir zu jeder
zeit genug ware zwar im backshop wird
nur noch aufgetaut und fertig gebacken
[Musik]
der handel bekommt also produkte die ja
nur noch fertig backen muss und hat eine
qualität und das ist halt das was der
kunde erwartet und das wird so hoch
industrielle fertigung zusatzstoffe und
einfrieren kann so ein brötchen
geschmacklich überhaupt noch mit einem
handwerks brötchen mithalten
wir lassen profis probieren die
prozesskosten sonntagsbrötchen von lidl
für 14 cent vom filiale bkk und um 44
cent vom handwerksbäcker für 60 cent und
von backwerk für 25 cent welches
brötchen ist sein geld wert
wieder wissen wie brot sommeliers nicht
von welchem becker welches brötchen
stammt los geht's mit dem will ich
brötchen von lidl für 14 10
[Musik]
wenig malt sich der duft lässt sich
morgens nicht aufstehen also das ist
sicher mein geschmack ist auch kein
könnte es auch sagen du machst 250 gramm
leberkäs rein und das ding team das die
finger nicht fertig werden von lidl
fällt auch das brötchen durch nummer
zwei kommt vom filiale becker
[Musik]
schöne bläschen und ein schönes
farbenspiel leicht meint ich wirklich
angenehmer brötchen geruch automatisch
ja jetzt gerade nach öl
also ist jetzt schon noch knackig
[Applaus]
gut gemacht
was sagen die experten zum brötchen vom
handwerksbäcker
schöner großer aus grund der der auch
darauf hinweist dass das von hand auf
gemacht worden ist ein brötchen wird
wirklich selbst morgen früh nord durch
sicherlich gut schmeckt die experten
sind vom handwerks brötchen überzeugt
das letzte kommt von backwerk
was ist eure crew in farbe her gar nicht
ansprechen so dass sogar das geschlecht
der einzelwert dieses brötchens ist dass
du danach was und auch rasch durch
gefallen auch wenn das brötchen von
backwerk günstig ist in den augen der
profis ist es sein geld nicht wert
handwerklich hergestellte brötchen sind
einfach besser beim brötchenkauf wird
sich jeder gesparte seien sofort auf die
qualität aus kommen eure brötchen vom
handwerksbäcker oder aus der schnellen
ladentheke sagt es uns in den
kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut wie die nächsten
zwei clips